what dude cut my hair again cuz I'm part
of a roll club as you know Oh what I'm
sorry I'm in an underground roll club
now roll yeah roll so you roll what I
grapple grappling not reduce if
grappling in general so [ __ ] it's it's
gross you're showing the fine stuff you
what must watch the fight this weekend
what was your favorite fight see here's
the thing who would you give Mac the
other night - okay hold on for a second
I was in a but just who was your
favorite
how about Sean O'Malley I know you
believe you are no matter you got la
mitad crazy [ __ ] Nazi so do this how
about Cody Gerber a three-fight [ __ ]
submitted to again what's with this
jujitsu [ __ ] huh guys you believe I'm
Anna Nunez I couldn't believe that but
she wanted open up baby bird your ii you
know ii Bassett may be the best athlete
in that house is I know you think it's
aa branch ah Chappelle's to 35 and can
do backflips and double back on oh
that's crazy how much mighty blade will
pro athlete I'm just sayin number
estimate how much money do you make is a
profit I'll just sit okay but then
Maulik how much my teammate is a pro he
had a hundred ninety amateur fights
amateur I'm saying dude don't teach
don't slap or no I love you fella oh
well populated with the big boys
Papa swim with a great white uh-huh yeah
there one slipped inside I said the
breath and I said round one that my go
we're talking about this guy's [ __ ]
like tough to me he's like [ __ ] me I
go how would you do against him so he
gets in my face were walking I don't
know Brian I imagine I do really well
because I fought for a living he never
he never competed once oh I forgot about
that detail but say you know you're not
in the conversation world's never
competed the moral of that story is
don't ever put your face in my face like
that again okay I'm glad I found sorry
baby ostrich you guys know Alexis
Ohanian her I don't he's the co-founder
of Reddit oh yeah he's got our own spot
first time I saw casting he's married to
Serena Williams
okay he looks a lot better I see he lost
weight he was in the documentary she did
how's it going well
so he Mayhew kid he's doing a big move
here I'll just play for you 15 years ago
i co-founded reddit as a place for
people to find community and a sense of
belonging it is long overdue to do the
right thing
I'm doing this for me for my family and
for my country I'm saying this as a
father who needs to be able to answer
his black daughter when she asks what
did you do so I have resigned
as a member of the reddit Board I've
urged them to fill my seat with a black
candidate and I will use future gains on
my reddit stock to serve the black
community chiefly to curb racial hate
and I'm starting with a pledge of 1
million dollars to Colin Kaepernick's
know your rights camp that's cool
I believe resignation can actually be an
act of leadership from people in power
right now and to everyone fighting to
fix our broken nation do not stop good
guy powerfully that's cool that's a good
guy that's cool all right I can't help
but think do you think he's a little
light in the ass for Serena Williams
that's all I think about
he's super holy talking about he's not
talking it's not that I've spent on what
no way he's not that I could have sworn
you know this all my maybe he's working
with something we just don't know he
might have that big old he's Armenian
and Armenians have got they got dicks on
this 5 6 5 it's pretty tall that stop
lying
do you know what I had him on the
podcast maybe I didn't mean it maybe he
just did the podcast papa he did the
Bryan Callen oh he's a big guy ain't it
you never did it I hate it he didn't
know you'd never in person no I guess we
did it by your lying mmm being small
yeah maybe I was a guy from reddit go
down there though six-five that's a big
guy all right well she's fine he's got
it he's fine though he's got a pepper
pepper pace up you know what he's not
lying the ass he's not lighting the ass
at all he's there another guy
you know Jim hunter Oh
you should feel back people are dying
for it like I swear my son just
yesterday and have to take up the shorts
neighbors can see you really want jacket
well the only reason you don't like that
is because you feel as though they're
gonna be like look at our biggest body
is well no cuz yeah unless you're unless
you ha ha skirt pops but we took me we
do pee in here together
like we do and what I say - I said digs
looking alright today you got a good
dick game today I peed in oh ha I peed
in the hanging low and you didn't think
you did I always feel like a wreck in
the sink and Brian washes in but in the
sink
well like nothing here but we're
basically house angels basically we live
life on the angels we use a sink for
wash Hells Angels like what there's
probably your dad if you can speak on
what you know what you grew up with what
your dad tells ya for a profession I
don't know if you know this beep now cuz
you've seen you know with your mom the
talent Whiteside being a superstar in
the NBA but also you know you your dad
kind of did the the dark arts yeah I
would say so you know my dad's no black
my mom's Italian the dark arts uh you
know so my dad grew up in it's getting
older now you know my dad was always
there but we never got along until my
mom died at 27 because my dad yeah my
mom my cancer so my mom died when I was
27 but my dad grew up in from a tough
you know a tough mom there was really
tough on him and made his life hell so
he never really grew up in love so he
never knew how to love so I grew up in a
drug-filled abusive household you know
where my parents were function
functioning drug addicts Bob yeah but my
dad was just hardcore so he was a
butcher by night and butcher by day and
drug dealer by night you know I mean it
was funny a little quick story while we
were little
well my dad would get off work he told
used to go make night runs to deliver
drugs and my brothers four years younger
than me so he didn't really get it I got
it but I was just so yeah I was you know
grew up with the seeing kit people do
cocaine right in front of me and all
kind of [ __ ]
my brother didn't really understand it
so when my dad would leave and I my dad
my brother for the longest time thought
my dad was a ninja until he wasn't
doing [ __ ] might have you know dressed
in all black or alesis where my dad was
a ninja you know what I mean
good-looking do ya we got no Tommy no
not about 510 so we just I grew up in a
very cheers boys cheers fellas thanks
for coming to a better world mm-hmm
I grew up in a like I said just a tough
household size I learned my hard knocks
early on you know I learned a lot of
stuff fast saw lettuce stuff fast and
was almost forced to understand the
world fast you know I mean so I grew up
with drugs violence and abuse but then
as soon as you know and then the next
thing added on to his race you know I
mean once we moved to Sacramento I
didn't see any racism when I was in San
Jose early on because everyone looked
like me or were close to me we're in the
same neighborhoods and we were fine
so I dreams all this childhood stuff and
then the next being thrown on top of me
was the race thing so I just always had
navigated and I've had an open mind from
a young from a young age because I've
had so much [ __ ] come at me you know I
mean some when people saw the basketball
player I was where I would fight in a
heartbeat or I was physical it was just
my that's how I grew up you know I mean
everything to me was it was a survival
of the fittest because I wasn't I was a
second round pick I wasn't in LeBron or
Katie you're Kobe none of these guys I
was someone who had a scratch and claw
to get my way into the league and once I
got I had to scratch and claw to keep it
you know what I mean so I was always
team yeah you know so you can you tell
the listeners and Brian like being draft
in the second round means nothing means
the odds of you making it even though
he's driving a semi not true hop high on
the top you know 40 players in the world
college the the chances of you making
the team as a second-round draft pick
not good is that true absolutely
most guys go cuz you played for 14
seasons yeah no it's not me first of all
that I have an average NBA career is
only three years so you know for me to
be a you know uh I think I was 46 pick
in the second round out of what 60 picks
or something there's two PS you thinking
the chances are very slim so I went in
thinking thinking like everyone else I
playing college ball in the NBA that's
why we are ever you can't tell a college
baseball player that plays at a major
school that he's not going to the NBA
and there
believe you like we don't like you don't
plan for nothing else but going to lead
but the harsh reality is is you're not
1% of student athletes go pro did you
did you watch the last dance doc mm-hmm
how goddamn good was incredible
incredible the way they would be able to
that's gonna sweep the Awards this year
for the house do the genre but the
ability to go back and forth on the
timeline so there's a little confusing
right I'll see ya but to me we never so
MJ was the one superstar that we'd
mentioned earlier there was never there
was in social media and he was a one guy
you saw play sold shoes and was the
owner and that's it
we never saw nothing else from Mike
we've heard stories that right so we got
to see the tail end of Kobe's crew we
got to see him open up on social media
and show who he is LeBron has been great
at if other stars we've been blessed and
people don't fans will understand how
fortunate they are because back in the
day we didn't get in none of this stuff
so you're so fortunate to be able to see
what these athletes lifes are and I
think instead of appreciating we want to
attack it but that's another subject but
we finally got to see this so to me the
last deck was on dance was almost like
social media for Michael Jordan but he
got to see the locker room we got to see
practice we got to see off the court him
in the hotel room you're right we got do
you know it yeah that [ __ ]
smoked wherever you want he smoked on
the plane he smoked he smoked a into the
hotel rewear cigars thank you where yeah
but in the locker room right after a
game he's smoking and drinking a bit
like drinking beer is no problem with
smoking anywhere like I smoked weed all
through my career but I had to like
barricade myself in my room at hella
candles incense put the towel down cool
yes yeah
this dude is walking into the lobby on
the elevator in the hotel lobby yeah you
know hallways just smoking it like there
was some stuff to me that like tripped
me up that I just thought was so dope
like he doesn't give a [ __ ] it's a gift